[Music]
okay let's get one game in we're 1863.
good
rating 1900
well
uh
what am i in the mood for is the
question
i am in the mood for
a sicilian let's play sicilian
bishop c4 so this is of course not a
first-rate move now there's nothing
inherently wrong with bishop c4 and
white can follow it up in a variety of
ways you know like knight f3 or c3 now
you don't want to commit to a setup too
early here so i don't love the move g6
this early you want to make a
development move that is going to give
you maximum flexibility and that
development move
is is in my view knight c6 this is the
most
uh open-ended move and f4 by wyden
transposing into some sort of a strange
grand prix attack with the bishop having
been committed
a little bit too early to c4 so how can
we exploit the uh premature development
of white's bishop to c4 i've talked
about this idea before and we would
quite possibly play it even if the
bishop was not on c4
and again to those watching on youtube i
apologize for the chewing i've got a
sore throat
and we go d5 with tempo so the bishop
looks really really dumb here
thank you golfer for the tier 1 edd
and bishop b3 so
why does flirting with disaster here c4
bishop a4 and the bishop
holds on by a thread
now i think a lot of you looking at this
position would be very tempted to play
b5 the problem with that approach is
that white has ways to defend against c4
you're not going to trap the bishop
because white can go c3 or i can go a3
and i'm not a huge fan of overplaying
the queen side like that it's a lot more
important to get your king side pieces
out
than it is to to try to trap your
opponent's bishop and play for gimmicks
so as unsexy as this move may seem
i like the idea of just developing
okay now we have a slightly sexier way
of developing
now
some of you might understand that rookie
one is is an idea that white has and so
you could get this bishop out to e7 so
that rookie one is not a check and then
you can castle
but if you want to play very ambitiously
you remember the idea that just because
a move isn't effective in one position
doesn't mean that you shouldn't consider
it
in another
and
if you look very carefully one thing you
might notice one thing that i've
no draw one thing that i've talked a lot
about
is when white pushes the f pawn
one of the the main weakness of that
move is that it it creates uh
vulnerability down the a7 g1 diagonal so
i might say okay well how do i exploit
that
i can't play bishop c5 check but what
you can do is play c4
and you might think that our intention
is then to get the bishop out to c5 with
check but
let's not hurry
you might say well okay i can also play
queen b6 shack but and both of those
moves are fun
but there is a tactic and if you look
very carefully
you can see
that you can use the idea of queen b6
and apply it in a much more dangerous
way
this is an amazing tactic what's the
move
you don't start with queen b6
you start with the move b5
and the idea is that after bishop takes
b5 you fork the bishop and the king with
queen b6 check and i didn't even see
this initially when when our opponent
castled
at first i i saw c4 with the idea of
bishop c5 but
this is amazing
oh and now
if you want to be if you want to take
this to the next level how should we
deal with knight e5
and this is really cool like we can give
queen b6 check
and then take on a4 but if you really
want to rub it in your opponent's face
we can just take on a4
first using the same tactic to pick off
the knight
knight d4 we take it
and it's important in such a position
not to rest on your laurels you know a
lot of people they win a piece and then
they get very disoriented you're like
how should we play
there's essentially two ways of thinking
here one one approach is just to play it
very safe
and just get your bishop out and then
castle and there ain't nothing wrong
with that with a safe approach
but um
if you want to play for for maximum you
could consider a move such as knight e4
um i i don't i mean knight g4 is also
very interesting and then bishop c5 and
you might have
ideas of developing a smothered mate
between 94 and ig4 i do like
94 more
because it it also closes the
uh the e file and so
it doesn't allow white to to defend the
f2 square with check
like white can still defend the f2
square with his queen but
uh you know he can't do it with check
and
this arrangement creates all sorts of
tactical concepts
and familiarity with uh you know basic
tactical patterns will help you find
them
now
some of you might be aware that bishop
g4 is an interesting idea bishop g4
queen takes g4
and then we're very very close to being
able to play queen g1 check
if rook takes g1 we have a mate on f2
the problem is that after
bishop g4 queen g4 queen g1 there's king
takes you on but you can set this up
you can set this up in a variety of ways
you can play h5
to prepare bishop g4 but a more elegant
way to do this is to play bishop c5 as
many of you have suggested and this also
prepares bishop g4 and i think we're
going to win this game precisely in that
way
i'm not a draw for
my guess is that our opponent is going
to go like d3
okay goes h3 so that's that's a good
move
but now we can take this
further to the next level
and make what incredibly powerful move
to reinforce the threat of bishop g4
what you may notice is that when you
haven't castled yet that could actually
be used in your advantage you can play
h5 and now bishop g4 is a threat why is
it a threat
because after h takes g4 you recapture
with the h-pawn
that is a check against the king that is
essentially checkmate
and there we go bishop g4
and this is a total beatdown
that is why you need an opening
repertoire at this rating because you
just
you know
otherwise you're gonna start getting
killed queen e3 is a nice move actually
um to be honest i didn't see it but in
another drawfur
and i've played people like that so
we shouldn't panic and our instinct in
such a position should be to simplify
the moment our opponent played h3
uh you should have uh noted that the
let me just decline the draw you should
have noted that the g3 square is now a
weakness so in your mind you should have
said well if the queen ever moves away
from f3 i'll have a fork on g3 so
combining that observation with this
position the simplest is just to take
the queen and then deliver a nice little
fork on g3 and then we'll be up a rook
and the rest will be really really easy
okay and there we go
yeah that was a nice game i mean it was
short but it was quite instructive
bishop c4 bishop c4 is already already
very dubious
and uh
you know if white wants to play this
line
all you have to do
is play knight c3
and then play a grand prix attack
um because once this already happens the
bishop just looks incredibly stupid on
on c4
now to make this work white should
probably have gone knight c3 here this
would have limited the damage because d5
is still impossible
but here black is
pretty spoiled for choice
we could play a6 to prepare b5 for
example that that seems like a good
approach the bishop is just very very
misplaced here
so knight f3 d5 trade
it should be three what if they go e5
if they go e5 then
oh i think there's 95.
there's this tactic when h4
i've seen this idea before so just note
this down by the way this kind of tactic
with a bishop on c4 and a queen on h4
so e5 isn't even possible
can't they just play a three
be two we guess
but but don't think of the point of our
play as being
to trap the bishop we're not trying to
trap the bishop we're trying to gain
control of the center
so the point of e65 isn't isn't that i'm
seriously
flirting with the idea of trapping his
bishop i didn't even realize that that
would be a possibility it's more that
we're just gaining control of the center
now our opponent should have gone to b5
where the bishop is at least doing
something
and
i think we've even had this type of
position before in the speedrun and the
setup that i that i recommend here
is to get this bishop out to d6
let's say white castles and then to get
the knight out to e7 this connects the
knights and just creates a very compact
and uh
manageable piece set up in the center
so i quite like this this arrangement of
pieces i like it more than playing
knight f6 here but after bishop b3 the
knight on c6 is not under pressure so
this changes the situation
especially since bishop d6 gives up upon
for no good reason
so for this reason we decided to amend
our strategy and to be honest i didn't
see c4 and b5 initially you know i quick
at first i was going to go c4 and then
bishop c5 check
now if white plays d4 we can on passant
with check
so
white has to move the king and i thought
we would castle and just have a great
position with good development
but then
you know then i spotted b5
and you might say well how did you
actually see b5
and
you know people watching this on youtube
or you guys probably will get a little
bit annoyed at my answer
you know i can give you all of the
tactical logic behind the move b5 and i
did right as soon as white played f4 you
should make the observation that this
diagonal is weakened
coupled with the fact that b5 is an idea
in such positions traps the bishop you
have to put two and two together but at
some point
you know you have to find such moves
subconsciously and that's why solving is
so important
right if you try to reason your way
through every tactic you're not gonna
get very far in blitz and rapid games
so
that is how tactical mastery works you
just see these kinds of moves without
actually consciously always making all
of the necessary observations which is
what happened here
and once b5 is played the game is over
i don't think white has any way to save
the bishop
um
i don't think white has any way to save
the bishop i mean why can give a check
on e1 but that doesn't change anything
we just block with our bishop
this maybe even makes things worse
queen e2 bishop e7 yeah it's over so and
b takes a4 is particularly nice and then
queen b6 check
but uh
you know in such a position if you're
not sure
uh if you're not sure about whether to
go for the kill
you should always err on the side of
of playing cautiously so a move like
bishop e7 here would be totally viable
as well and you're just up a piece
so don't feel like you always have to go
for the kill as soon as you want some
material
it's just that
white was so undeveloped here that
you know i it's clear that black can get
away with this
yeah chess is is largely pattern
recognition bishop c5 threatening knight
f2 and threatening bishop g4
so the actual idea is to play bishop g4
queen g4 and then the smothered mate
queen g1 and knight f2
it doesn't lose another piece knight e5
doesn't actually lose another piece it
because
he actually took the knight on c6 so it
was just a trade
any questions
five the white pieces i resigned
at this point you know white's last
chance is to play d3 here preventing c4
once once once c4 is allowed i think
it's over
okay
all right guys it's getting late i'm
pretty under the weather so i'm gonna uh
get go to bed but i hope you enjoyed
thanks everybody for the support
means a lot thanks everybody for hanging
out
have a good one
[Music]